it's been two weeks since I got apples
Pro display XDR and it's time to get
honest was it really worth $6,000 well
for me yes but I will have to say it's
definitely not worth it for everybody
that can afford it some of you guys
should spend way less while others
should actually spend more and in this
review I'll explain exactly why and pit
this aluminium slate against
alternatives ranging from $1,500 all the
way up to $40,000 and tell you why
$6,000 isn't really overpriced
I'll talk about the strengths of the 6k
and the one big issue that plagues it
which is causing some people to return
them and why Apple had to make this
compromise that not everybody will like
let's start off with the design and I
have to say that it's amazing sure not
everybody will like the look but the all
aluminum build makes it very rigid while
also acting as a heat sink and the
lattice pattern cutouts allow for
passive cooling even though it's not
super thin it is much thinner than other
high brightness displays and unlike many
of those the xcr stays completely silent
the infamous stand is the highest
quality most stable stand that I have
ever used and I love the quick magnetic
attachment I've talked to many people
that bought an X dr and every single one
of them also ordered the stand and are
very happy with it
the only complaint some of them had
myself including is the price the stand
really should have been around $500 and
the VESA adapter about $100 but that is
Apple being Apple on the front the
entire panel is glass with bezels that
are really impressively thin especially
for the size of the display now if you
opt for the nano texture model
reflections are all but gone without
having that ugly matte coating which
ruins contrasts and smears detail but I
didn't offer that one overall the look
and feel of the display is top-notch it
really complements Apple's computers and
gets their approval of all the people
who pleaded for another Apple display
for so many years and now many of them
can finally ditch the LG if I can
displays that they despised if they can
spend this much money that is just like
the LG 5k and the display has no power
buttons
menus or anything else it is controlled
through the only available input which
is Thunderbolt 3 this makes it super
simple to use and you can adjust the
settings and brightness with software
through your Mac but that also limits
the capabilities when you're in Windows
unlike the LG the XDR uses newer
DisplayPort technology which not only
allows for 6 K and 10 bit HDR but it
also makes a compatible with more
computers which we showed off in our
first test video definitely check that
video out after this one but to give you
a quick overview the XDR has great
backwards compatibility and will even
work with the 2013 mac pro or the older
MacBook Airs using a Thunderbolt 3 to 2
adapter but keep in mind that the
resolution will go down to either 5k
like on the iMac pro or MacBook Air or
even down to 4k like with the trashcan
Mac Pro's that is because their graphics
cards and sometimes our Thunderbolt
ports can't handle this many pixels
especially if you're trying to get
10-bit color on the plus-side many
Windows PCs and laptops can actually
power it some even at 6 K and on the Mac
side even a MacBook Air with integrated
graphics can now be used to view true 10
bit colors which is a huge feat and I
will cover exactly what this means in
just a bit it also has three USB type-c
ports which can support USB 3.1 speeds
but if I plug this $6000 display into my
$15,000 Mac Pro these ports turn into
USB 2 and instead of running my 800
megabyte per second SSD at just over 400
megabytes per second it will run at 40
megabytes per second yes that is right
we are going back to the year 2000 at
the same time if I connected to a base
16 inch MacBook Pro it will not only run
at 6 K 10 bit HDR but it will also get a
full USB 3.1 speeds that's because the
current graphics cards in the Mac Pro
are a generation older just like the
IMAX and the older Mac Book pros which
don't support display stream compression
and a 6k 10 bit ACR signal needs a
massive amount of bandwidth about 2.5
times that of a pro 4k display now Apple
does have the W 50 700 X coming out soon
and it will be cheaper and the
this issue now before I get into the
biggest complaint pro color graders have
with this monitor I want to give a huge
thanks to my Crescenta for making our
pro xcr content possible micro Center
has 25 stores nationwide with an
impressive variety of electronics from
gaming VR computer parts like processors
graphics and everything else needed to
build or upgrade a PC or Mac micro
Center has been an Apple authorized
dealer since 1980 they have a dedicated
Apple department with highly trained
Apple sales associates a site from the
iPhone Micro Center carries the full
lineup of Apple products and they have
the largest selection of third-party
accessories for Mac and iPad come into a
local Micro Center today and talk to one
of their Apple experts to order the
specific Mac Pro configuration that best
suits your needs or a pro display XDR
check out the link in the video
description to find a location near you
or to browse all of micro centers Apple
products now let's get into what makes
this monitor stand out compared to the
LG 5k and Apple's previous cinema and
Thunderbolt displays first off the build
quality is the best ever for an Apple
display and of course it is larger and
6k compared to their last display which
was the 27-inch 1440p thunderbolt
display which does help out with real
estate when working and looks
dramatically more detailed which really
helps for editing photos and high-res
videos at first the 32 inch size seemed
huge as I was used to the 5k 27-inch
screens but after a day or two I got
used to it and I love the extra space it
offers especially when editing videos
some asked why do you need a 6k display
to edit for Kane well I can have a video
preview that can display my 4k footage
pixel for pixel at a hundred percent
while having enough room for the UI
which really helps to judge noise focus
and more the other way it stands out
compared to Apple's displays and their
LG partnership is colors contrast and
brightness
it supports true 10 bit colors meaning
you will see over 1 billion colors
compared to 16 million on the Mac books
the IMAX and their other displays which
is great for professional color work
what's even more noticeable is contrast
Apple has always been praised for their
displays and they are good but when you
push them to the extreme
they cannot compare to the XDR which in
most conditions looks as good as OLED
but gets brighter the last is the
support for HDR and a sustained 1000
nits in a peak of 1600 this is what
makes it really expensive and why Apple
compared it to Sony's $40,000 reference
monitor but it wasn't really a fair
comparison and I'll explain why the LG
5k and most current Mac's can run at
about 500 nits which is bright and the
previous Apple displays could do about
350 which is what most monitors still do
today this really helps in bright
environments and I was really hoping
that the XDR could be pushed up to say a
thousand but unfortunately a normal use
you're still limited to 500 that extra
brightness is reserved for HDR that's
what you're really paying for this
monitor and not only HDR playback but
good HDR grading capability so if you
don't need that then that is at least
$2,000 out of the 6,000 dollar price tag
that is sitting there unused personally
I really wish Apple made more than one
display a new 27-inch 5k possibly an
OLED without that's the same peak
brightness buffer say $2,500 and then
this Pro XDR for those that really
actually need it since I think that most
people buying the XC are are doing so
just because they want a sharp color
accurate display that matches their
Mac's which I guess is just a win for
Apple if they're willing to pay that
extra price to get it now for that
specific use case which is partially why
I have it you can look at it as an
amazing value if you buy apples
comparison to the reference displays or
as an incapable display if you're
somebody that actually uses those types
of screens I've spent days researching
and getting feedback from a mix of
professionals and the truth is somewhere
in between there are people out there
that are over praising this display
because for their standards it is
amazing and I'm partially in that camp
as well and that's also those that are
dissing it and possibly on purpose
undermining it by posting exaggerated
images like this one the truth is the
XDR is the do-it-all display it's full
of compromises and it's imperfect for
many very specific tasks but considering
the
price point in everything it offers it
is a fantastic compromise a jack of all
trades but master of none if you
consider the price point that's because
Apple is not a display company and they
don't want to offer dozens of monitors
for different use cases like Asus does
if you want ultra-high resolution for
coding by an 8k or a 5k Dell display for
way less if you want a thunderbolt
display with good accuracy for photo
editing by the LG 5k and if you want a
budget display just for entry-level HDR
grading by this Asus for $1,500 and the
list just keeps going on if you want the
best contrast with no blooming fine OLED
but that won't work as well for grading
since the peak of brightness is usually
about 800 nits and it gets dramatically
worse if you use the full screen which
is why Apple didn't use OLED well Apple
decided is to make a high-end screen
that could do everything quite well one
that looks fantastic matches the Mac
Pros and of course costs a lot but is
fairly reasonable and actually it's
quite good for HDR editors compared to
the competition for example Asus has a
new 1200 netpeak rightness display that
costs four thousand dollars and it even
has more dimming zones but they don't
quote the sustained brightness and the
build quality is lower it is thicker the
fans could be quite loud and has two and
a half times less pixels so if you want
to have a super sharp display then that
won't work they also have a new model
coming out soon with the same peak and
the same brightness but there is no
price listed it will be at least five
thousand dollars possibly six thousand
dollars or more so you can really start
to see the value of the XDR when
compared to other prosumer displays and
even then the xcr is more than twice the
amount of pixels way better materials
design and more now Apple didn't compare
it to those displays they went in for
the reference displays and that's what
really pissed off a lot of the pros the
thing is these pros don't need a 6k
display 4k is actually better for them
and this is not going to be the only
display that they set up so it doesn't
need to look so nice and pretty
they also grade in dimly lit rooms so
that their eyes are influenced and they
use dedicated hardware between their
computers and their displays to get the
absolute best color accuracy and often
times the companies that they are
grading for require approved
place that cost 30 to $40,000 the xcr
will not be an alternative to those
displays but it will allow everybody in
the pipeline to still view content way
more accurately before handing it off to
the main color grader a few of these
people have already complained and
posted images in super tough situations
where the X CR has bloomin issues and
yes this is true but these images were
shot on cell phones which bring up the
dark parts of the image and make it look
much worse than in reality as you guys
can see in this is a cell phone shot
compared to my actually adjusted camera
we did our own torture tests and
accurately showed off this issue in our
comparison but in these environments
even the praised IMAX will look super
great everywhere the X Y R and other
hand will have this around small sharp
super wide objects and this is with the
brightness up at a max 500 nits here's
what it looks like with the normal
webpage when I record with the camera at
500 nits I did my very best to show you
guys a real-world accurate recording of
this blooming so I went back and forth
between recording and viewing on my
computer since camera displays are very
inaccurate and here are the honest
results if you are working in a very
dark or pitch-black room and have a
white sharp line at full brightness on a
pure black background you will notice
blooming like this if you cut it down to
50% brightness it dramatically gets
reduced and when you turn it down to 30%
brightness which is around what Apple
actually locks you in if you're using
the HDR grading mode it all but
disappears not only that but if you
don't just have a very thin bright line
or text you say something like this
paragraph the effect is cut down
dramatically and a 50% brightness it is
not noticeable and the same thing goes
when playback actual HDR footage with
lots of bright spots on a pure black
background at 50% brightness it looks
fantastic and of course when you're
using it in a normally lit room like
most of us will this is a complete
non-issue even at full brightness it
looks gorgeous especially if you're
playing back 6 key or a cave footage
pros are making us think about this but
this also goes for the competing asus
displays which do have more dimming
zones but lack some of the other specs
and even many Pro grading displays that
have been you
for years and are still being sold like
the display on the left which has over
two thousand zones and is now on sale
for twenty two thousand dollars instead
of thirty seven thousand since that has
been replaced with the one on the right
that has better technology and goes for
thirty five thousand in one way I
understand why it's getting some hate
from the pros that are buying these
displays but on the other hand if this
display can perform closer to a now
twenty two thousand dollar one and
doesn't need dedicated hardware to be
color accurate but has hardware profiles
built in and programs like DaVinci
Resolve for the first time ever are
confident enough to allow it to be used
without the external hardware then I
think this is the perfect display for me
Apple had a tough choice to make and
they wanted an aesthetically pleasing
Mac light display that was larger but
maintain sharpness in provided accurate
colors in high sustained brightness
while being slim and silence compared to
these huge reference boxes and a
reasonable price point for that use case
while being somewhat attainable by other
pros that might be buying a Mac Pro and
I think they made a very good compromise
for the one single display that they are
gonna sell if you are grading Hollywood
movies with hundred million dollar
budgets you shouldn't use this display
but if you want something that is a
great middle ground for a variety of
professional work this thing is a treat
thank you guys for watching click up
there to subscribe to see more videos
and check out our other display xtr
videos right over there this Ben Max and
I will see you in the next one
[Music]